bonjour les faits clinton touche
l'heure de vérité notre invité du jour à
41 ans cinq ans de moins que le futur
président des états unis monsieur bayrou
bonjour vous êtes agrégé de lettres vous
avez été professeur dans plusieurs
lycées de pau avant d'entrer dans la
politique une entrée qui s'est faite en
deux temps d'abord du cabinet
ministériel du cabinet avec messieurs
méhaignerie power puis melun dans
l'ordre le ministère de l'agriculture le
sénat et le parlement européen et
ensuite alors il ya six ans l'entrée par
la grande porte lorsque vous êtes devenu
député des pyrénées atlantiques en 1986
votre ascension a été rapide très rapide
même aujourd'hui vous êtes président du
conseil général de votre département
vous êtes vice président du cds et
secrétaire général de l'udf c'est à dire
numéro deux juste derrière monsieur
giscard d'estaing alors l'actualité
n'est pas avare de thèmes de réflexion
cette semaine qu'il s'agisse de la crise
ouverte en europe par les négociations
du gatt des rebondissements de la sphère
du sang contaminé du discours prononcé
jeudi soir à carmaux par le président de
la grille et de la présentation de votre
propre programme de gouvernement fait du
programme de gouvernement de l'udf cette
semaine alors nous parlerons de
l'actualité du moment avec albert du roy
puis de l'après mars avec jean marie
colombani monsieur rap monsieur
mitterrand rappeler à carmaux que rien
n'était joué d'avancé mais quand même il
y a de bonnes chances que vous
remportiez les législatives et que l'un
des vôtres s'installe en avril à l'hôtel
de matignon
alors comment les choses se passeront
tel avec le président de la république
commencera seront tels avec vos alliés
du rpr avec lesquels vous l'avez
toujours pas réussi à élaborer un
programme commun de gouvernement et bien
vous le dirai à jean marie colombani et
puis nous parlerons de façon un peu plus
détaillée de l'un des points de votre
programme les remèdes à apporter à
l'éducation nationale et la crise
qu'elle traverse
la question sera au centre de la
campagne des législatives comme elle l'a
été aux états unis pour l'élection
présidentielle vous avez été professeur
vous avez six enfants
vous avez écrit un livre intelligent sur
la question la décennie des malappris
publié en 1990 chez flammarion
benoît pro rédacteur en chef du magazine
l'étudiant vous fera passer l'oral en
fin d'émission on commence tout de suite
par albert ii roi
bonjour sur les négociations sur le
commerce international qu'on appelle
donc les négociations du gatt le la
france par la voix de son gouvernement
vient de refuser l'accord qui a été
conclu entre les états unis et les
commissaires européens
est-ce que vous approuvez ce refus
j'approuve ce refus mais je n'approuve
pas les conditions la démarche qui ont
fait que nous nous trouvons aujourd'hui
isolé en réalité nous sommes dans la rue
un mot sur la démarche et après on
revient rapidement refus parce que ce
sac et l'actualité en réalité non un mot
sur la situation si vous si vous voulez
bien nous sommes dans une double impasse
nous sommes aujourd'hui acculer à
choisir entre deux crises soit une crise
européenne soit une crise agricole
nous sommes acculés ou bien abandonner
nos agriculteurs ou bien à abandonner la
solidarité européenne
et ceci est une faute de démarche de
négociation de la part du gouvernement
français
et donc les responsables de cet échec
c'est évidemment le gouvernement
français bon alors qu'on peut regretter
ce qui ce qui a conduit la france dans
ce deal devant ce dilemme qui est un
dilemme impossible mais bon le résultat
est là on y est
alors entre exactement comme si vous
disiez on peut regretter les raisons qui
ont fait que nous sommes à waterloo mais
bon on y est oui nous sommes à waterloo
alors alors il faut creuser la question
tout aujourd'hui une soufflante des
responsabilités on est donc aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas me semble-t-il d'autre
choix que de dire non que d'opposer
notre droit de veto contre choisi
mais ne le voit pas mais on a pas on n'a
pas le choix que parce qu'on ne peut pas
trahir une deuxième fois les
agriculteurs français enfin il faut se
remettre en mémoire ce qui est arrivé ce
qui est arrivé est très simple pendant
deux ans le gouvernement français nous a
dit nous ne signerons pas l'accord sur
la réforme de la pac tel qu'il est ils
l'ont dit à tous leurs interlocuteurs
et puis un jour sans débat au parlement
sans en parler à qui que ce soit sans
avertir les les agriculteurs français
ils ont fouillé la réforme de la pac et
le la très grave erreur est de ne pas
s'être assuré que cette réforme de la
pac n'allait pas entraîner d'autres
enfin n'allez pas nous mettre en
situation de faiblesse supplémentaire
par rapport au gatt
il aurait fallu être assurée certain que
les concessions nous les avions déjà
fait qu'après la première vague de
concessions il n'allait pas y en avoir
une seconde aujourd'hui les agriculteurs
français découvrent avec stupéfaction
que la viande bovine le lait
pardonnez-moi fait une seconde le
président du conseil général des
pyrénées atlantiques qui qui pense aux
agriculteurs des pyrénées atlantiques la
viande bovine le lait se trouvent en
situation d'avoir à consentir des
sacrifices nouveau et bien cela est
inacceptable
on ne peut pas faire autrement que de
dire non mais il faut mettre en cause la
responsabilité de ceux qui nous ont
conduits dans cette impasse dans cette
grave impasse aujourd'hui il fait
traduire monsieur vers maza haute cour
comme le demandent certains manifestants
paysans non n'exagérons pas soyons
gardons de la modération à l'égard des
des hommes
cependant monsieur mermaz porte une
responsabilité politique très importante
bon et le gouvernement autour de nous
revenons à une question qui va vous être
posée à vous députés mercredi débat au
parlement annoncée par le premier
ministre
et vous le savez déjà il là il l'a dit
le premier ministre demande à demandera
que la position
le refus de la france face à cette
négociation se soit une position non pas
du gouvernement mais de la france tout
entière représenté par les principales
formations politiques
est-ce que devant une situation
difficile grave
est ce que c'est une union sacrée vous
va nous le soutiendrons dans ce refus
mais nous ne l'exonère rompt pas des
responsabilités qui sont les siennes le
soutiendrai danse et refuser que ça peut
se traduire par un vote unanime ou quasi
unanime à l'assemblée nationale moi je
pense que oui mais je ne connais pas
encore les textes les positions qui vont
nous être présenté ce qu'il faut demandé
aujourd'hui au gouvernement français
c'est de bien vouloir nous dire et dire
aux agriculteurs quelles sont les
perspectives
car dire non ça ne suffit pas jallet
qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière ce nom
qu'est-ce qu'on va proposer qu est ce qu
on veut obtenir pour la pac est ce qu'on
vous demande une renégociation du gat
qui je vous le rappelle touche
l'ensemble du commerce mondial avec 108
108 pays
est ce qu'on demande une renégociation
du gatt ou est ce qu'on demande une
renégociation de la pac et quels sont
les concessions qu'on veut obtenir le
faut que le gouvernement nous indique
est pourquoi je peux pas vous dire quel
sera notre vote faut que le gouvernement
nous indique quelles sont les
perspectives de son refus on dit en
général que la partie agricole de ces
négociations représentent à peu près 10%
du total
et voilà pourquoi l'élève est ce qu'on
va est ce qu'on va condamner à la guerre
commerciale les 90% restants ou non de
l'aviculture
vous êtes en train de décrire très
exactement la victoire grave de
négociations que le gouvernement a fait
il nous a laissé isolé et il a laissé is
les l'agriculture par rapport au reste
il aurait fallu éviter ce double
isolement et je puis vous assurer que
des responsables précédent méhaignerie
ou giscard ne l'aurais pas fait est ce
que tout le monde depuis 30 ans n'isole
pas l'agriculture dans la simple mesure
où pas vous en est une illustration
vous êtes libéral vous défendez des
thèses libérales et ce que l'agriculture
ne vit pas en france depuis très
longtemps sous 1 grâce à un
protectionnisme de tous les instants qui
est tout là c'est contraire à la théorie
libérale
pardonnez-moi françois henri de virieu
est un spécialiste agricole tournez vous
vers lui il va vous dire une chose
simple moins que vous dimanche la grille
culteurs toutes les agricultures du
monde vivent avec des aides et il faut
penser le libéral que vous êtes ne dit
pas il faut petit à petit en sortir je
dis il faut en sortir de manière
progressive et sans sacrifier les
agriculteurs français et c'est tout
l'enjeu il y a eu des négociations
agricoles entre 74 et 90 il ya eu des
difficultés de cet ordre est ce que vous
vous souvenez que nous nous soyons
trouvé isolé de cette manière pas une
fois vous ne pouvez pas citer un seul
exemple eh bien tout ça ça prouve en
clown entre temps la thèse libéral dans
le monde ont quand même le deviendrait
ce jeu là prouve qu'il y a des
responsabilités très importante
on est devant un problème très grave
posée
non pas tellement aux hommes politiques
il va être posée dans leur lit aux
agriculteurs français et leur vie est
déjà tellement difficile tellement
difficile que on n'a pas le droit on
n'aurait pas dû avoir le droit de les
mettre dans cette situation là vous êtes
convaincu d'être en situation de leur
donner satisfaction au lendemain de mars
sera extrêmement difficile
bon deuxième sujet d'actualité la haute
cour de justice qui va théoriquement si
la procédure judiciaire aboutit se
réunir dans la sphère de la
contamination du sang est ce que vous
partagez la position
du président de votre groupe
parlementaire charles millon qui
regrette que l'ancien premier ministre
laurent fabius et été associé par les
sénateurs vos deux autres ministres
responsables de la santé nous avons dit
avec jacques bas et avec charles millon
qui sont présidents des deux groupes udf
à l'assemblée
nous avons dit que les responsables moi
même fait des déclarations sur ce sujet
que les responsabilités de laurent
fabius était moins direct que celles des
deux autres ministres pourquoi ça mérite
qu'on y revienne
une seconde parce qu'il n'ya pas une
affaire du sang il y a deux affaires
puissant il y à une affaire du sang d'un
degré de gravité probablement jamais
atteints c'est la sphère des hémophiles
pourquoi parce que vous savez les
hémophiles sont atteints par une maladie
qui empêche la coagulation du sang
ils ont une vie qui était vraiment
absolument presque impossible pouvait
pas se laver les dents et c'est parce
qu'il avait des hémorragies tout le
temps et on découvre il y a plusieurs
années un facteur de coagulation qu'on
peut injecter qui s'appelle le facteur 8
pour fabriquer ce facteur 8
il faut mélanger écoutez bien cinq mille
poches de sang qu'on brasse et dont on
extrait le facteur ce qui fait que
lorsqu'une poche et contaminé sur 5000
l'ensemble des 5000 se trouve atteintes
par le virus
on savait donc qu'il y avait 100 % des
produits qu'on vendait qui était qui
apportait le mal qu'ils apportaient le
sida 100%
il n'y avait aucune espèce de chances
qu'on puisse en sortir
et malgré cette certitude scientifique
qui est acquise depuis 18 mois au moment
des faits mais en tout cas de pic depuis
le début de l'année 1985
malgré cette certitude la décision est
prise de repousser l'introduction des
produits chauffés dans lequel le virus
est inactivé à octobre 1985 et elle est
prise par qui et bien je vous ai apporté
l'arrêté ministériel au journal officiel
lillers première ligne le ministre des
affaires sociales et de la solidarité
nationale et le secrétaire d'état auprès
du ministre des affaires sociales c'est
à dire madame du foie monsieur hervé
rete pays décident
vous avez un texte de là il décide de
reporter au 1er octobre la distribution
des produits chauffés
leur responsabilité est directement
engagée ensuite il y à une deuxième
affaire survenir à faire là les
laboratoires mérieux ont continué à
vendre le facteur 8 plus tard donc je
veux dire qu'il ya des gens qui savaient
et c'est pas pour ça qu'on a pris des
décisions et bien ya faute si c'est vrai
hier faute rapidement parce que deuxième
affaire deuxième affaire qui est celle
de laurent fabius mais où il n'est qu'un
directement en cause d'affaires très
simple on a retardé de plusieurs
semaines les tests de contamination
c'est à dire vous savez que tous les
donneurs de sang fait un test pour
savoir si ils ont ou non le virus du
sida ils sont non porteurs du virus du
sida
on a retardé de six semaines sous la
responsabilité de monsieur gros qui
était le conseiller de monsieur fabius
et au nom de monsieur fabius le
programme à leurs gros du professeur
gros on a retardé de plusieurs semaines
la généralisation du test pourquoi parce
que le test français n'était pas encore
prêt et donc des raisons économiques
voilà donc les deux affaires alors et
les deux responsabilités il faut dire
que monsieur fabius
à partir du mois de juin c'est à dire
assez tôt à changer la décision qui
avait été prise par le professeur vaut
cela dit pendant quelques semaines sa
responsabilité et indirectement en cause
voilà pourquoi on n'a pas du tout le
même niveau alors de responsables ou un
mot quand la tuer avant de passer à
autre chose
en prenant comme hypothèse que
la phase juridique l'instruction fait
part des magistrats de la cour de
cassation ou que la phase politique
c'est à dire le jugement par la haute
cour aboutissent à l'équivalence pas
comment ça s'appelle en termes de haute
cour l'équivalent d'un non lieu
en ce qui concerne l'une des
personnalités politiques ou les 3 est-ce
que davance vous dit ce sera une
décision que je respecterai et que je ne
critiquerai pas je respecte davance
évidemment cette décision comme les
autres cela dit je viens de je viens de
dire qu'il y avait à mon avis une nette
différence de degré dans la
responsabilité entre les seins madame du
foie et monsieur hervé et l'autre
monsieur fabius et ça ne ment mais que
que plus à l'aise pour dire à quel point
un grand nombre d'entre nous ont été
j'allais dire bouleverser profondément
choqué par la déclaration à mes yeux un
digne du président de la république qui
a dit à carmaux dans un discours destiné
à remobiliser l'électorat socialiste
c'est son affaire ça n'est pas la mienne
il a dit qu'il y avait là une recherche
d'affaires très fut alors si les mots
ont un sens et pour monsieur mitterrand
les mots ont un sens filet il est pétri
d'histoire ça veut dire en faisant
référence à l' affaire dreyfus que l'on
poursuit un innocent parce qu'il est
juif parce qu'il est juif
et bien moi qui a bonne mine
l'antisémitisme pour des raisons on
explique généralement pas télévision qui
a bonne mine
cet antisémitisme là je dis que monsieur
mitterrand recherche une diversion par
des moyens indignes je ne connais
personne parmi les hémophiles
parmi les associations personne parmi
les hommes qui réfléchissent à cette si
douloureuse question qu'ils aient eu une
seconde à l'esprit les origines
prétendue ou réelle de monsieur fabius
dans cette affaire chaque fois que
monsieur mitterrand est en situation
difficile chaque fois il remet sur la
table des problèmes de division et de
diversion et bien parler d'antisémitisme
à propos de cette affaire là c'est une
honte
c'est une honte je n'aurai pas le temps
d'aborder les affaires politiques vais
laisser ça à mon ami john rées colombani
après je vais continuer sur les
questions d'actualité en a une troisième
le verdict du procès de reims
la boulangère a quitté après avoir tué
quelqu'un un jeune qui avait avec
d'autres envahi son magasin
est-ce que ce verdict d'acquittement
vous a troublé je me suis dit que si
j'avais été à la place des victimes et
de ses proches et de ses proches
j'aurais été bouleversée mais on met des
jurys populaires on décide depuis
longtemps qu'il ya des cours d'assises
en france
je suis je voulais dit tout à l'heure à
un autre propos pour le respect des
décisions de justice
est ce que à votre place la semaine
dernière le président d'international en
des termes sur ce plan là très modérée a
dit il faut quand même entamé une
réflexion sur le fonctionnement des
jurys populaires
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
déclaration il faut réfléchir à ce
problème non je suis favorable au
maintien des cours d'assises
mais je suis favorable au maintien des
jurés populaires parce que il y à bien
des problèmes sur lesquels on essaie
toujours de parler à la place du peuple
et comme si on voulait dissoudre le
peuple le peuple ne ne satisfait pas ce
qu'il dirige et bien moi je trouve que
on a raison de mettre des jurys
populaires et on n'a pas raison de
ralentir les enquêtes et d'empêcher ces
jurys de s'exprimer je pense à une autre
boulangère qui elle a été assassinée qui
a été victime elle sort dans la rue elle
voit des voyous en train de de molester
son fils hémiplégique paralysé qu'ils
avaient pris comme souffre-douleur
elle sort c'est elle qui se fait battre
et elles en meurent rien n'a été fait
sur ce sujet mais le traumatisme
provoqué dans les banlieues par ce
procès ne vous inquiète pas farce
verdict jeu le jeu le mesure je le
mesure ils m'inquiètent mais nous avons
en france des lois une justice eh bien
il faut les respecter
merci albert du roy on enchaîne avec
jean marie colombani mais vous venez que
même de dire votre répulsion pour
l'antisémitisme mais vous avez dit pour
des raisons qu'on aborde généralement
par la télévision
vous pouvez en dire plus
monsieur de virieu je crois à un dieu
qui avec les juifs
une histoire d'amour et de douleur de
maintenant je ne sais pas trente trois
siècles il les a d'abord choisi pour
leur donner la loi et l'alliance et puis
il a fait naître en leur sein jésus de
nazareth et à cause de ces deux choix de
dieu ils ont beaucoup reçu
et ils ont beaucoup souffert beaucoup
souffert ce qui fait que ils sont des
étrangers absolue mais pour moi ils sont
pas des étrangers
jean marie colombani et on va faire un
peu politique mais avant je suis bayrou
je voulais revenir d'un mot sur ce que
l'année dernière question d'albert il ne
vous a pas échappé malgré tout que en
france il ya une anomalie juridique qui
est que les cours d'assises les
décisions des choristes ne sont pas
susceptibles d'appel ce qui est quand
même quelque chose d'assez assez
aberrant
ça n'entre pas dans les plans les
projets de l'opposition de remédier à ce
jeu cela dans mon avis mais il ya dans
cette salle des spécialistes de ce
projet de justice plus importants que
moi je pense que nous n'avons pas
envisagé cela parce que il y a dans la
notion même de jurés populaires
il y à 7 comment dirais-je cet abandon
que le pouvoir fait au peuple d'avoir à
juger à partir d'un certain degré de
gravité bien l'échéance politique qui
est devant nous c'est bien sûr
législatives on en dire un mot mais
c'est aussi là l'éventualité d'une
cohabitation
alors je voulais savoir comment vous
même vous aborder cette échéance est ce
que vous pensez qu'elle est normale
naturelle inévitable
et si oui comment comment gérer d'abord
il ya des éléments nouveaux
je veux dire pour ceux qui en doutaient
encore monsieur mitterrand s'est situé
cette semaine à carmaux il s'est situé
comme le chef de guerre de son clan
comme le chef du parti socialiste qu'il
a cherché à mobiliser pour qu'il mène la
bataille des élections on était nombreux
à ne pas avoir de doute sur ce sujet
alors ça c'est votre analyse quelles
conclusions en tirez-vous
la conclusion que j'en tire c'est la
même depuis longtemps je n'en ai jamais
changé c'est celle qu avec raymond barre
nous développions 1986 et qui l'a
développé hier encore dans le monde
absolument il n'y a pas on ne peut pas
lorsqu'on est président de la république
qu'on a inspiré la politique suivie
pendant 12 ans on ne peut pas se sentir
à l'abri de la sanction que le peuple
apporte à cette politique là on est
forcément atteint on est forcément en
cause banc et donc le président de la
république devrait doit à nos yeux se
sentir responsable de la politique menée
je reviendrai une seconde sur ce mot
responsable de la politique menée et
doit en tirer les conclusions
ovi pardonnez moi je voudrais liés en
une réflexion quel est le mal français
et je crois que vous venez de dire vous
même dans un
très beau livre que vous avez écrit sur
ce sujet quel est le mal français au
coeur de tous les problèmes que nous
évoquons et qui paraissent distincts les
uns des autres
il y à un facteur commun il y a un virus
commun et ce virus c'est
l'irresponsabilité
les gens font des choses elles ont des
conséquences douloureuses ou dramatique
et il s'estime ne pas être lié par les
responsabilités qu'ils ont prise ils se
sentent à l'abri de toute sanction
c'est la même chose si vous y
réfléchissez bien c'est la même chose
pour les très douloureuse affaire que
nous venons de voir et pour l'attitude
que monsieur mitterrand a choisi de
prendre je ne suis pas en cause je suis
à l'abri de la sanction que je vais
recevoir demain cela dit en corse de
l'année les institutions organisent
l'irresponsabilité du président de la
république ça c'est une chose que vous
savez et deuxièmement apparemment
d'après ses déclarations il n'a pas du
tout l'intention de partir après les
législatives donc il va bien falloir que
vous que vous acceptez sa présence est
bien jeunes udf n'est pas composée de
putschiste il est possible que nous
ayons à l'accepter mais autre chose et
de s'en satisfaire
je trouve que à tout le moins nous
devons l'oppposition tous ensemble
considérer que ce n'est pas une donnée
acceptable considérer que ce n'est pas
acquis considéré qu' on a le droit de
poser le problème devant l'opinion
publique et non pas de s'en satisfaire à
l'avance je souhaite que l'opinion
publique française les électeurs
français et les hommes politiques
français rappelle cette doit selon
laquelle quand on sanctionne les
exécutants le gouvernement où
l'assemblée on sanctionne l'inspirateur
l'inspirateur c'est monsieur mitterrand
il doit être au premier chef mise en
cause par la sanction qui va bien cela
dit le président de la république donc
ne manifeste aucune intention de partir
et il va bien falloir désigner un
premier ministre
ce premier ministre à votre avis est-ce
qu'il devra sortir des urnes du mois de
mars c'est à dire est-ce qu'il faudra
qu'ils nomment
monsieur giscard d'estaing si l'udf
votre mouvement à plus de députés que le
rpr ou monsieur jacques chirac si le rpr
a plus de députés que l'udf et question
subsidiaire comment vous organisez-vous
à l'udf pour avoir plus de députés que
le rpr tout cela dépend bien entendu de
la marge de la victoire de l'ampleur de
cette victoire d'abord s'il y aura
victoire moi je ne suis pas de ceux qui
à l'avance indique que tout est joué
mais les sondages semblent le prouver
donc s'il y a victoire et si cette
victoire est très importante
encore une fois je ne considère pas
comme acquis que monsieur mitterrand
reste je pose
il me semble que l'opposition doit poser
la question raymond barre a encore posé
cette semaine nous sommes nombreux à la
pause et il n'y a pas ce n'est pas joué
à l'as vence le peuple français peut
dire par son vote qu'il considère qu' il
faut maintenant ouvrir une page nouvelle
il faut commencer un chapitre nouveau
cela dit donc je reviens à ma question
est ce qu'en tant que responsable
politique vous avez affaire à ces choses
là chaque jour
comment faites-vous pour arriver devant
le rpr est ce que vous allez multiplier
les puits ce qu'on appelle les primaires
dans les circonscriptions où bien ce que
un état-major vous et alain juppé allez
vous mettre d'accord pour que ya des
candidatures uniques dans toutes les
circonscriptions je vais peut-être
est-ce que la bonne la bataille existera
entre le rpr et l'udf je vais peut-être
vous surprendre je considère que la
question principale aujourd'hui n'est
pas celle de la prééminence de l'udf sur
le rpr ou des repères sur le tf ce n'est
plusieurs projets communs
ce n'est pas la question principale
pardonnez moi c'est une question
ça fait toujours plaisir on aime mieux
être à la tête d'une formation
victorieuse que d'une formation qui
arrive seconde c'est jordao que on a le
premier ministre c'est évident jean
marie colombani
pardonnez moi c'est une question
accessoires la question principale c'est
que les français qui sont complètement
je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
que ça peut-être à paris on s'en rend
moins compte
mais les français qui sont profondément
décourager et je dirais presque
désespérée en réalité ils croient pas
que ça va changer en mars croit que les
hommes vont changer mais je suis pas
persuadé qu'ils croient que la politique
va changer sur la politique de l'heure
cela même si l'homme est d'abord genou
rage on évacue ses ces questions qui
alors attendez moi quand je vous dis la
question principale c'est que nous
fassions partager aux français l'idée
que quelque chose peut changer en bien
pour eux c'est pas seulement le jeu
l'équipe qui est au pouvoir
déjà voir quel état major cissé juppé ou
moi qui importe en quelque chose change
rend mieux 6 élise plus de députés udf
ou caselli donne la primauté repères
pour qu'ils croient que quelque chose va
changer en mieux il faut d'abord que
nous soyons unis et il ya un signe
extrêmement simple union c'est que nous
réussissions à présenter un candidat
commun
dans chacune des circonscriptions
françaises les imaginales ce stade c'est
curieusement il ya désunion que d'union
un vol et cela vous dit cela et
j'appelle al'inverse qu'est ce que les
français dirait si les écologistes
arrivent à s'entendre pour avoir un
candidat commun dans chacune des
circonscriptions et si nous en étions
incapables donc l'accord que nous avons
signé depuis longtemps et l'accord que
nous respecterons je le crois c'est que
nous aurons des candidats communs dans
l'immense majorité des circonscriptions
françaises qu'elles savent dire
l'immense majorité 90% des
circonscriptions françaises raisonnement
qui est valable après pour l'élection
présidentielle où l'un nous y venaient
d'accord juillet vers la ration de van
reeth quart des 700 rsa un côté pour que
les gens pensent que quelque chose de
changé
il faut que nous leur montrions que nos
rivalités intérieure ont moins
d'importance pour nous que leur sort que
nous nous occupons d'abord d'eux et ils
ont envie de cette réunion n'a rien pas
là mais alors concrètement vous
d'autres et aussi d'un candidat unique à
l'élection présidentielle si j'en crois
les riches touristes dont vous allez
organiser des primaires nous avons signé
cet accord depuis longtemps cet accord
ce doit être des c'est très important
beaucoup de gens parlent des primaires
qui n'y croient pas et moi j'aime y
croire à vrai dire et moi j'y crois j'y
crois de manière simple parce que je
pense que ça n'intéresse pas que
l'opposition ça intéresse les
écologistes qui ont à choisir entre la
londe et wechter ça intéressera les
socialistes demain qui ont à choisir
entre de leur regard ou un troisième ça
peut intéresser l'ensemble des grandes
formations politiques françaises et
c'est une démarche qui consiste à dire
ce choix si important de l'homme que
nous présenterons aux sélections nous
n'allons pas le faire dans un couloir
d'appareils de 2,2 d'alliance des uns
contre les autres comme au congrès de
rennes pas faire de manoeuvres autour de
ça on va confier le choix aux français
et pour ça il faut connais une procédure
honnête loyal est possible d une
l'oiseau de feu qu'on est noir et je me
réjouis de vous entendre françois henri
de virieu reprendre une idée que j'ai le
premier avancé et pour laquelle je me
suis fait exécuter leur espace de 24
heures qui est qu'en effet il ya
aujourd'hui des dispositions
législatives qui interdisent des
primaires et il faudra donc une loi qui
ouvre cette possibilité à toutes les
grandes formations politiques françaises
ça vous aurez sans doute tout loisir de
le faire un mot encore pour en terminer
sur ce sujet naturellement vous le
secrétaire général de l'udf votre
candidat c'est giscard ou alors ça ça
n'est pas giscard dites-moi qui c'est
parce que
comment concilier cela d'ailleurs avec
ce que disait françois henry en
commençant l'émission l'effet clinton ou
et l'effet clinton le candidat à quelle
élection à l'élection présidentielle
écoutez vous parlez d'une élection qui
est absolument pas ouvertes moi le jour
l'élection présidentielle sera ouvert
elle est dans tous les esprits n'aurait
qu'une ligne vous souhaitez nazisme vous
souhaiter que françois mitterrand s'en
aille vous avez bien ça en tête très
bien je n'aurais qu'une attitude je
choisirais celui qui est le meilleur
pour la fonction est au fond quand je
regarde l'histoire après tout on a le
droit aussi de regarder l'histoire même
quand on est con à cinq ans de moins que
le nouveau président des états unis
d'amérique est un adolescent comme
chacun sait on a le droit à un peu de
s'interroger winston churchill
quand je me demande s'il a été meilleur
premier ministre quand il avait 40 ans
ou quittant haut quand il en avait 60 et
quelques je me dis que je le préfère la
seconde fois que la première et je ne
sais pas si je suis tout seul
parmi les cadrages nerfs à imaginer cela
mais je pense que l'expérience ça compte
aussi voilà qui va faire plaisir giscard
bon on va en vous c'est pas spécialement
fait pour lui faire de la peine entre
nous
les gens variés on va revenir sur votre
programme les gars évidemment plein de
choses on va je vais essayer de limiter
à quelques coins sans trop bon quand on
regarde le programme que vous avez
cosigné avec alain juppé il ya plus pour
la justice plus pour la défense plus
pour l'espace rural plus pour les
professions de santé est moins pour les
impôts alors je vais pas vous demander
comment vous faites
évidemment pour dépenser dépenser plus
d'un côté et avoir moins de recettes de
l'autre j'aurais me concentrer sur deux
aspects l'impôt sur le revenu qu'est-ce
que quelles sont vos propositions en
matière d'impôts sur le revenu et
l'impôt sur la fortune qu'est ce que
vous faites de l'impôt sur la fortune
l'impôt sur la fortune à mon avis on n'y
touche pas cela dit il ya des
propositions d'en haut rang au sein du
rpr pour qu'on prenne en compte la
résidence principale le quotient
familial etc
mais ça une telle charge symbolique que
je considère que c'est pas du tout parmi
les urgences qu'on y touche
quant au second sujet ne sais pas si
vous avez lu un autre très beau livre
qui vient de sortir qui est le livre de
jean françois revel sur contre le
présidentialisme à la française et idy
si vraiment on continue a expliqué qu'
on ne peut pas dépenser mieux en france
alors on continuera à augmenter tout le
temps des impôts nous avons le devoir de
faire les deux choses à la fois dépenser
moins et dépenser mieux
ou bien dépenser moins parce qu on
dépensera mieux il ya des tas de d'état
d'administration qui sont complètement
absorbés par leur poids leur dimension
leur taille salut en france bâle
nous allons parler éducation dans une
seconde ans au bureau salle est vrai que
jean lardin président d'univers et
interrogé sur la route je vous dis un
exemple simple un président d'université
en france ne peut pas acheter pour son
université
une voiture de plus de 5 chevaux sans
obtenir une autorisation ministérielle
voyez ce que ça représente comme l'être
mais secrétariat fonctionnaires ou qui
s'interrogent ils vous vous allez
développer tout ça
à l'instant sur la recette vous savez
bien qu'il ya un débat il ya des gens
qui à droite disent eh bien on va la
jouer simplement là le taux le taux
supérieure d'impôt sur le revenu 58% on
va le ramener à 50% il y en a d'autres
comme raymond barre qui disent attention
il faut refondre l'impôt sur le revenu
et élargir son assiette c'est à dire
faire en sorte que des gens qui
aujourd'hui ne paient pas l'impôt sur le
revenu le paye
alors quelle est votre position alors je
moi j'appartiens plutôt à la deuxième
école qui veut il arrêta dire je pense
qu'il faut refondre l'impôt sur le
revenu il ya trop peu de français qui le
paient donc il faut mais il faudra venir
o'donnell le paye non ce n'est pas les
petits relais vers le mas faut une
charge faible sur un très grand nombre
de gens
mais je vous dis là une position
personnelle parce que nous avons débat
sur ce sujet et nous arrêterons notre
position vous avez dicter leurs quelque
chose de un peu inexactes a dit qu'on
n'avait pas réussi à se mettre d'accord
c'est pas vrai nous avons choisi un
calendrier
je n'ai pas su pardonner mais nous nous
avons choisi un calendrier dans lequel
nous arrêterions notre plateforme
à la fin du mois de décembre pour
l'adopter en janvier et dont le
calendrier
je pense que il faut que beaucoup de
gens aient moins paix peut beaucoup de
gens paix peut plutôt que d'avoir un
très petit nombre de gens qui sont
écrasés par l'impôt normalement un mot
encore déjà dans l'opposition il y a des
gens qui jugent que le l'effort social
la dimension sociale n'existe pas dans
ce programme je pense à charles pasqua
et philippe séguin comment bien ce
qu'ils n'ont pas lu le programme de
l'udf qui porte comme titre un nouveau
pacte social oui mais qui à l'intérieur
vous l'avez peut-être lu dans les
journaux spécialisés qui s'étonnait que
nous puissions être avoir mis à ce point
au premier rang de nos responsabilités
dans ce texte qu'alain madelin
représenter avoir mis autant l'accent
sur le social c'est pour une raison
simple la société française est coupée
en deux et il faut la recoudre la
reconstituer bien merci
jean marie colombani on enchaîne avec
loi producteur en chef du magazine
l'étudiant sur un volet important de
votre programme qui est l'éducation la
formation benoît bon monsieur bayrou
j'ai relu votre bouquin avant de venir
préparer cette émission et j'étais
frappé de la cellule rappel le titre la
décennie des malappris 1990-2000 donc on
parle en fait des gens qui viennent de
rentrer en sixième et qui passeront le
bac en l'an 2000 le moi j'étais frappé
de la sévérité de votre constat sur le
système éducatif actuel
à vous écouter il est inefficace et en
plus de ça il est injuste et je pense
que si vous aviez à le noter vous ne
voudriez pas la moyenne c'est évident et
l'appréciation serait quelque chose
comme peut beaucoup mieux faire
d'où ma première question toute simple
qu'est ce qui ne marche pas dans l'école
aujourd'hui en france il ya beaucoup de
choses qui marchent pas il ya au moins
trois ou quatre choses qui ne marchent
pas ce qui ne marche pas c'est
l'acquisition des bases la lecture
l'écriture ça ne marche pas ces crèches
vainement piste d'un propos non c'est
républicain c'est élémentaire appelez ça
comme vous voulez c c'est vrai
deuxièmement ce qui ne marche pas c'est
la culture la culture qui est une
dimension essentielle de de la vie des
hommes ça ne marche pas troisièmement le
métier marche pas on donne pas de métier
à l'école ou plus exactement quand on
sort de l'école on a beaucoup de mal à
acquérir un métier et 4ème ans qui
marche pas c'est l'orientation
on peut pas développer ses capacités
alors je je reviens aux plus graves
j'ai dit ça par ordre l'hiérarchie qu je
reviens aux plus graves ce qui ne marche
pas ce sont les bases
je vous ai apporté un document officiel
ce document officiel
c'est le bilan par la direction
nationale de l'évaluation du ministère
sur les connaissances des petits
français à la fin de la cinquième
comparé aux connaissances des mêmes
petits français deux ans avant à la fin
du cm2 les mêmes mesures et au cm2
mesurait deux ans après la fin de la 5e
et je vous lis le premier part
rave du bilan il existe par rapport à la
fin du cm2 globalement une progression
deux ans globalement une progression
moindre des choses celle-ci toutefois
écoutés bien cette phrase c'est la
première est relativement faibles en
lecture également peu importante pour la
résolution de problèmes en mathématiques
elle est nul en orthographe et on
observe une baisse du taux de réussite
aux opérations qui étaient communes aux
deux niveaux
ça veut dire simplement si cette phrase
a du sens et c'est encore une fois la
direction du ministère qui l'a fait
qu'entre la fin du cm2 et la fin de
cinquième
les petits français ont plutôt reculé si
vous trouvez que ça vaut la moyenne et
une estimation flatteuse je suis alors
écorné les faits avant une question
complémentaire sur le constat qu'est ce
qu'on risque si vous appelez votre
bouquin est décédé des malappris vous
êtes beaucoup intéressé à l'illettrisme
et vous savez mieux de personnes que
grosso modo 30 % des français ne savent
pas lire ne savent pas écrire ne savent
pas compter donc que l'école
effectivement pour eux étaient
totalement inefficace le risque ce que
vous vous appelez le risque des
malappris où le risque américains c'est
quoi qu'est ce qu'est ce qui sépare est
simple c'est ce que nous avons sous les
yeux
vous savez qu'on a beaucoup fait de
commentaires autour des résultats du
référendum de la coupure de la france en
deux et je parle pas politique la part
de la société française il me semble
qu'il ya je ne leur apporte pas du tout
résultat du référendum pour moi mais il
me semble que il y a dans la société
française
pour simplifier une moitié qui suit est
une moitié qui suit pas et je crois que
la rupture entre les deux et peut-être
même un jour l'affrontement entre les
deux est un véritable risque ya à cela
des raisons qui tiennent à la politique
générale le monde rural les vallées
pyrénéennes sont des lieux abandonnés çà
çà tient la politique générale faudra
faire de l'aménagement du territoire
selon une manière différente et donner à
ces gens le sentiment qu'ils ont un
espoir mais il y a dans les villes même
les plus riches
des gens qui ne suivent pas parce que
ils n'ont pas le niveau nécessaire parce
que les problèmes dont on parle ne les
concerne pas parce qu'ils se sentent
sans chance et ça c'est la
responsabilité de l'école vous avez dit
tout à l'heure elle est inefficace et
injuste
pour moi il est encore plus grave c'est
vrai pour moi il est encore plus grave
qu'elle soit injuste que inefficace
qu'est ce que vaut aujourd'hui angers
non mais qu'est ce que vous allez on va
essayer de changer sa défense et reste
voilà voilà gens sont d'accord
voilà le sujet je ne sais pas si
beaucoup de gens sont d'accord avec le
constat voilà le sujet que nous allons
traiter alors qu'on nous allons nous
intéresser à son efficacité et à sa
justice et bien concrètement il faut
d'abord reprendre les choses à l'art à
la base à la racine s'est intéressée à
l'école primaire s'intéresser à la
manière dont on apprend à lire à l'école
primaire et je vous assure qu'il ya
beaucoup à dire et à faire et accepter
une démarche toute simple qui est la
démarche de responsabilité dont je
parlais avant responsabilité en
particulier des enseignants et soulevé
de très concret c'est à la base
effectivement les âges idées les plus
originales que vous développez c'est
l'idée effectivement on joue la carte
des enseignants on leur fait confiance
et on va pour arriver à ce qu'ils aient
enfin la considération n'ont pas joué
sur les salaires parce que les salaires
c'est pas l'essentiel en plus de savoir
non plus les moyens pour être très clair
donc on va jouer effectivement le fait
qu'ils vont être fiers de leur travail
et pour ça on va les évaluer
systématiquement tout le temple du
molard soyez concrets et comment ça va
se passer
abbas est très très simple on va essayer
de mesurer
on va prendre du moins je l'espère ce
qu'on commence à faire à l'heure
actuelle meurt on n'en tire pas les
conclusions
on va essayer de prendre 400 prof de
maths qui ont la même classe et on va
voir qui amène sa classe le plus loin
sont des classes du même niveau avec les
mêmes problèmes
400 classes de banlieue ou 400 classes
de centre-ville où 400 caisses de
campagne et on va voir qui va le plus
loin
et une fois qu'on sera qui valent plus
loin on demandera à celui là de bien
vouloir expliquer aux autres comment il
fait
car c'est quelque chose qu'on oublie
tout le temps l'école ça se passe dans
la classe ça se passe pas dans cet
immense architecture administrative ça
se passe dans la classe donc
décentralisation responsabilisation à la
base en bas là où les élèves rencontrent
des profs des enseignants alors on va
regarder par exemple quelles méthodes
apprend le mieux à lire savez qu'il ya
des débats théologiques depuis des
décennies sur le fait de savoir si la
méthode globale ou la méthode
traditionnelle le semis globale ou la
semi global qui est une globale qu'on
déguise tout autre chose
si ça marche ou pas pourquoi on ne
mesure pas pourquoi on n'essaie pas de
savoir concrètement simplement
humblement voulez que je vous dise moi
j'ai une vague idée mais j'ai pas de
préférence ça m'est égal que l'une
méthode marche ou l'autre pas ce que je
veux c'est que les enfants apprennent à
lire comme et d'ongles décentralisation
responsabilisation évaluation comment
est ce que vous ne faites accepter ça
aux enseignants et notamment aux
syndicats d'enseignants
je suis persuadé que les enseignants
savent aujourd'hui qu'une certaine
époque syndicale est finie que l'époque
où on se posait à tous c'est fini que
l'époque où on traduisait tout
uniquement en terme de budget c'est fini
enseignants ils veulent s'investir et
moi je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de
richesses en eux qui a beaucoup de
travail chez eux c'est le geipan en vain
oui qui a beaucoup de travail chez eux
beaucoup d'entre eux qui ont trouvé des
moyens originaux de transmettre ce
qu'ils ont à transmettre et à qui
personne ne s'intéresse jamais eh bien
je n'ai pas envie de faire une énième
réforme contre les enseignants
j'ai envie que les choses changent avec
vous jouez les élèves et les parents
vont vous jouez eux-mêmes aussi
l'enseignant qui est essentiel
le savez vous jouer quand même aussi sur
la carotte et le bâton puisque ce qu'on
voit dans le le programme que je signe
effectivement avec madelin juppé sarkozy
c'est l'idée qu'on va
s'occuper moduler la rémunération et la
carrière des enseignants en fonction des
besoins et de la réussite ça veut dire
quoi ça concrètement ça veut dire qu'on
va enfin envoyer le profane henri iv en
banlieue parce qu'on aura plus besoin de
lui là ça veut dire qu'on va payer
d'avantagé prof de maths parce qu'on en
a pas qu'on va payer davantage les profs
à lille parce qu'ils veulent pas y aller
par exemple oui mais je veux dire
simplement que il y a dans l'éducation
une espèce de de suicide organisée qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui on trouve plus de
profs vous le savez bien il y a des
matières entière où on n'arrive pas à
remplir la moitié des places mises au
concours les lettres classiques la
physique les mathématiques peuvent pas
bien qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire on peut
les mieux traités aujourd'hui un jeune
prof du sud-ouest qui entrent dans
l'éducation nationale
l'ordinateur l'envoie à 800 km de chez
lui et sur les classes les plus
difficiles dont personne ne veut d'un
système absurde qui fait que les moins
formés les moins expérimentés ils ont à
s'adresser aux élèves les plus
difficiles
combien de temps allons-nous continuer
comme ça à coude ordinateur et
d'absurdités moi je voudrais qu'on les
traite mieux et naturellement dans les
traités mieux même si c'est
révolutionnaire
il ya aussi un peu prendre en compte les
réussites qui sont les leurs
et d'ailleurs c'est déjà le cas les
notations actuelles elles sont bidons
elles sont fausses elles n'ont pas de
crédibilité mais les notations actuelles
c'est un peu ça tout de même on
introduit le mérite à l'intérieur mais
que la carrière dit vous même le ne
veulent strictement rien et voilà nous
sommes deux aldi deuxième point deuxième
point les mots magiques qu'on entend et
qu'on entend beaucoup dans votre camp
c'est effectivement vous l'avez employé
plusieurs reprises décentralisation vous
croyez réellement que décentralisation
de changer quoi que ce soit à ce monstre
alors c'est vrai que l'éducation
nationale c'est plus d'un million de
salariés c'est le quart du budget de
l'état c'est le deuxième employeur du
monde après l'armée rouge mais avec
cette différence énorme
mais rouge décrite l'éducation nationale
continue à recruter mais vous croyez
vraiment que la décentralisation ça va
changer quelque chose je crois qu'elle
peut changer beaucoup je ne pense pas
qu'elle puisse tout changé et j'ai
l'honnêteté de dire que parmi les
systèmes d'éducation au monde
il y a deux systèmes qui marche très mal
système anglais le système américain de
sont décentralisées tous les deux et un
système qui marche assez bien c'est le
système allemand il est décentralisée
aussi c'est donc c'est pas la clé unique
la décentralisation
cependant il ya des choses qu'il faut
décentraliser tout de suite c'est pas la
clé unique mais c'est déjà un motif de
conflit entre nous puisque assise à la
même place que vous monsieur séguin a
dit l'autre jour si on décentralise
l'éducation nationale c'est la caille
bien je vais vous dire vous lui poserez
la question philippe séguin pense
exactement la même chose que moi et que
ce qui est écrit dans ses notes très
clair bon allez je vais je vais et il le
répète chaque fois qu'il peut ce qui
d'ailleurs me fait plaisir besoin de
l'occasion de dire que j'ai aussi de la
sympathie pour lui et donc c'est faire
bien donc il ya des choses qu'il faut
décentraliser tout de suite
et qu'est-ce qu'il faut décentraliser
tout de suite en particulier notre plus
grand échec c'est la formation
professionnelle le ciss vraiment cela
est complètement en panne cela est un
gravissime échec pour la france faisons
confiance aux régions et aux entreprises
c'est d'ailleurs déjà un peu dans la loi
mais on ne le fait pas faisons-leur
confiance décentralisons il a tout de
suite il ya quand même effectivement un
certain nombre de cacophonie au sein de
l'opposition là dessus quant au leader
différences d'expression
disons différents expression quand on
lit le programme du cds on voit
effectivement moi j'étais très surpris
que cds propose programmes récents sur
un document du 3 4 mois que le cds
propose que le recrutement les
enseignants du primaire et du secondaire
soit redonnée aux académies donc
décentralisés aux académies ce qui
semble à priori à vous même et beaucoup
de gens une folie totale
c'est en tout cas une grave imprudence
pour les profs 1
je crois que c'est un que c'est un
système auquel il faut beaucoup
réfléchir il faut pas le retenir en
revanche faut faire confiance aux
académies tout de suite sur quelque
chose
pourquoi ne pas leur donner le moyen de
recruter des auxiliaires ou des
professeurs supplémentaires dont on
manque
parmi la société civile est-ce que les
réunions je vois conter une histoire
dans un lycée à côté de pau que j'aime
beaucoup
il y à des professeurs de lettres qui
manquent à côté porte à porte
il ya un très brillant professeur de la
sorbonne rue retraités qui s'ennuie un
peu
enlève ton qu'on demanderait pas
accessoirement de bien vouloir faire
quelque chose là dessus d'accord c'est
vraiment à tout le monde d'accord
personne le fait international
locataires dit voilà mais je faisais
plein d'idées d'où ma dernière question
qui est en fait une devinette quelle
différence entre un optimiste et un mort
j'ai dû j'ai dû écrire ça ainsi que
c'est que c'est que le moule mort layton
optimiste qui était un ancien ministre
de l'éducation nationale face à votre
réponse réponse c'est que ce sont tous
les deux des ministres réformateurs de
l'éducation nationale
alors là c'était avant et l'autre alors
d'où la dernière question vraiment la
dernière et dernière j'ai ressenti
passionné par ces sujets là on sent que
vous aimez ça vous avez été enseignant
est ce que vous seriez prêt en mars
prochain à aller au charbon et avoir le
courage politique de mettre en pratique
tout ce que vous venez de dire je me
suis fait une règle c'est que comme je
connais au moins trois ou quatre
candidats par portefeuilles ministériels
disponibles éventuellement au mois de
mars je ne parle jamais de ces sujets
c'est beaucoup plus à vous seriez pas le
moins performant à priori mais à disons
que sans échéance c'est un sujet un
dossier que naturellement j'aimerais
j'aimerais beaucoup mais je ne pose pas
ma candidature à quelques ministères que
ce soit voilà merci bonne approche
alors c'était donc l'heure de vérité de
monsieur françois bayrou secrétaire
général de l'udf peut-être peut-être
futur ministre de l'éducation nationale
rediffusion cette nuit sur france 2 à
1h40 et de mâts et demain à 11h sur tv5
europe prochaine invitée l'homme qui au
gouvernement s'occupe du dossier des
négociations commerciales du gatt
monsieur dominique strauss kahn
le ministre de l'industrie on parlera
avec d'agriculture bien sûr on en
parlera aussi des 14 autres dossiers
qu'on oublie un peu dans les discussions
monsieur strauss kahn a accepté de
retarder de 24 heures son départ en
indonésie pour être présent dimanche
prochain à l'heure de vérité et ce soir
ce soir dans le journal de 20 heures de
france 2 monsieur pierre bérégovoy sur
cette question du gatt dans 5 minutes le
journal présenté par paul amar bon
appétit à tous et bon dimanche
[Musique]